mais pour le moment on a voulu faire un
que sont ils devenus sont des gens qu'on
a aimé que vous avez aimé puis tout d'un
coup il disparaît de la télévision et on
pense qu'il disparaisse tout court de la
vie et pourtant écoutez ça
ça va partir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle est avec tout et cindy sanders est
avec nous
nouvelle cas en 2008 rappelez vous eh
bien ils s'étaient bien moqué d'eux ils
ont bien eu tort regardez son passage à
nouvelle star la secte en faisait un
petit peu t'en as pas mon shoot comme ça
un petit peu too much à l'époque
regardez comme en 2008 la france
découvre ébahi et cindy sanders
de trois mois de super kitsch bâton deux
fois moi c'est une séance de torture je
veux juste qu'on vous arrêter de chanter
cindy sanders est humilié devant près de
5 millions de téléspectateurs et la
toque jeu rare et je me dis c'est pas
c'est pas logique que je trouve pas une
maison de disques m'a déjà ou quelqu'un
qui croit un petit peu avoir décidé à
réussir elle enregistre dans sa cave
quelques jours plus tard le titre
papillon de lumière
[Musique]
la presse s'en empare elle devient culte
elle est même parodié sur internet
incroyable car
paraît-il que quand vous avez passé le
casting puisque ça que vous en faites un
peu des tonnes c'est ce qu'on vous avait
demandé c'est vrai le public ne s'est
pas tout c'est que moi je suis arrivée
au casting en voulant j'entends chanter
une chanson très soft ouais c'est quoi
déjà non pas du tout non je suis passé
déjà dans un premier temps devant le pré
jury ouaip a d'abord eu il ya d'abord
voilà d'accord là bref et là on me dit
alors ce qu'il faut savoir aussi c'est
que je faisais la queue dehors pendant
huit heures et on m'a fait doubler tout
le monde donc déjà là on se posait déjà
la question pourquoi comment méheut
savait déjà où il voulait en venir c'est
à dire se foutent de ma gueule bah oui
bien sûr oui d'accord et et puis en fin
de compte on m'a fait passer dans le pré
jury on m'a dit voilà nous on sait ce
que la prod veut où il veut l'une blonde
comme ça comme ça tu vas faire un medley
il faut vraiment faire des caisses a une
super voix et ira en finale à ce moment
là je pense que comme n'importe quel
jeune artiste qui a envie de faire
carrière dans la chanson on est aveugle
et partent avec calage à l'époque
c'était il ya plus de 14 ans ouais ouais
donc j'étais encore on va dire que
j'étais mal entouré j'étais naïve je
pensais que c'était un peu le pays des
bisounours et je me suis laissée
manipuler j'ai passé mon casting le
lendemain devant le jury ouais je fais
ce qu'on me dit comme une bonne élève et
là on met la manucure dit ça regarde
camélia-jordana déboule à 16 ans les
grosses lunettes je crois que c'est une
blague et tout d'un coup elle où la
gauche à se met à chanter what a
wonderful world elle nous présente
quelque chose qu'on n'a jamais entendu
la nouvelle star c'était ça le problème
c'est que vous avez été instrumentalisé
par la prod qui s'est dit ça va être la
candidate idéale et par les médias juste
de transition âge il ya juste un livre
un kiki qui est où un mot qui raconte ce
qu'on vous a fait c'est le schpountz de
marcel pagnol fernandel vous connaissez
un là je m'attendais pas du tout à ça
et là vous rentrez chez vous forcément
et commente les pires moments de ma vie
parce que très souvent le public est
très méchant les médias sont très
méchants heureusement que j'avais mon
petit garçon qu'il n'est de l'âge de 4
ans qui me prenait à l'époque à nancy
c'est ça non j'habite toujours dans ma
maison tu regardais ma maison vous avez
un peu d'argent votre fils je vivais
normalement larry avait son travail je
vivais normalement je vivais pas dans la
pauvreté je vais bien mais j'avais plus
envie de rien je pense que si j'avais
pas vu ma famille je serais pas assis
ici ce soir à savoir les as oui ça peut
être ça peut aller très très loin les
gens ne peuvent même pas s'imaginer la
violence voilà moi je chante depuis tout
petit j'ai fait le conservatoire je suis
pas une céline dion je sais juste que je
sais chanter aujourd'hui alléluia j'ai
eu mon grand bonheur manfred tirer
mugler qui a cru en moi et grâce à lui
je vis de ma passion aujourd'hui voilà
et ce qui est malheureux aujourd'hui
c'est que les médias disent des choses
qui sont pas vraies très souvent et le
public croit beaucoup de choses
malheureusement aujourd'hui bon mon
image heureusement a bien changé on les
gens commencent à voilà mais il ya
toujours ce cindy sander qui reste j'ai
la preuve manfred avait présenté la
maquette à des grands producteurs ici à
paris et il leur a dit cécile descendeur
ils ont dit au nom orsini s'endort on ne
veut pas bien sûr mais s'il est revenu
quelques temps après il a présenté la
même maquette
il a dit c'est une jeune québécoise
écoutez là ils vont dire mais elle est
merveilleuse quelle chance d'y renoncer
discute mal à blanc quand tu fais
papillon de lumière est ce que moi ma
question vraiment c est ce que tu
puisses tu essaies de surfer sur
finalement ce bad buzz qui t'a fait
souffrir est ce que tu es premier ou
second degré lors de papillons lula
effectivement on j'avais des gens autour
de moi qui m'en dit samedi dans l'état
où ça se passe maintenant joue vas-y à
fond utilise tout ce que tu peux
utiliser mais le problème c'est qu'après
ça donne toujours plus une image
toujours plus une image heureusement
comme je le dis j'ai eu ma belle étoile
sur la tête qui a fait que il m'a retiré
des médias pendant au moins trois ans
c'est josé parce que c'est important
pour les gens qui nous écoutent et les
gens qui justement veulent la lumière un
peu trop vite trop longs effectivement
dit que quand tu es rentré chez toi tu
as eu des idées noires oui mais à ce
point là oui c'est est restée pas eu d
enfant ou ton mari te tue si j'avais pas
eu mon fils ma maman ma belle maman et
mon mari je ne serais pas là aujourd'hui
je vous le dis parce que les gens
étaient très mechouar nature quand même
non j'ai pas fait de tentative mais j'ai
pensé et repensé j'ai pensé parce que je
me disais je demande quoi juste à
chanter mais on me laisse pas cette j'ai
chanté depuis l'âge de 9 ans g tous les
gars là une région disait comme
violences étaient dans la rue mais toi
sous une voiture
et 30 toi t'es qu'une grosse merde tu
sers à rien sur terre fin des mots si
quelqu'un est fragile pour un peu il
peut et c'est très dur parce que j'ai
toujours chanté depuis tout petit j'ai
fait le conservatoire j'ai toujours
chanté j'ai vu je vivais de sa déjà à
l'époque et quand j'arrive à la télé on
me dit ça pour moi ça a été très très
dur après je demande pas avoir la place
de the key mais sinon oui entre le
moment où est à ses idées noires et tout
ça est le moment où après ça va mieux
pour toi où il ya effectivement moins de
fred qui s'occupe de toi il ya eu
quelques années oui c'est quoi ces des
années de dépression tu es chez toi tu
es tout seul avec va dire que après la
nouvelle star il ya bien eu deux ans
malgré que je faisais beaucoup de médias
beaucoup de projets
où je n'étais pas à ma place je me suis
pas senti même j'ai chanté des chansons
qu'on va imposer on m'a mis un look
parce que elle voulait que j'ai ce look
je devais avoir les ongles rose fluo
c'était voilà et puis à un moment donné
on signe un contrat et je me dis mais
quelle merde j'ai fait parce qu'il n'ya
contrat avec m6 à l'époque oui il voyait
bien sûr pour un album oui j'avais fait
des chansons avec eux j'avais fait des
tournées etc ils ont ils ont bien sûr
fait sur mon dos comme que tu en veux à
m6 aujourd'hui donc j'en veux à personne
j'en veux à personne parce que je me dis
que dans mon malheur j'ai trouvé ma plus
belle étoile et aujourd'hui je vis de ça
pour moi ma plus belle victoire
aujourd'hui c'est de vivre de ça
aujourd'hui ce que je voudrais c'est que
les français comprennent que je suis une
artiste mais mon plus grand rêve c'est
ce qui se passe à l'étranger j'aimerais
finale alors j'entends parler mais ça
veut dire qu'à la vertu remercierai mme
c'est aujourd'hui oui une sur malgré
tout
et alors effectivement thierry mugler
oui à 1 quittée il ya peu de temps
malheureusement effectivement et ben tu
n'as coup s'intéresse à toi et de
produits en 2010 est d'abord ton premier
ep et puis fait de toi s'amuse un show
en allemagne tu deviens une énorme star
et quand je dis une énorme star eh bien
je trouvais parce que nous on a fait un
documentaire sur toi je dis nous c'est
idiot prix ce qui est apparemment la
production pour t'avoir on a dû passer
par un agent on a dû avoir tiré mon père
qui donne son nom ne veut dire la vérité
on a dû je veux dire la vérité te loger
dans la suite du fouquet's et moi j'ai
juste fait mon cas des villes et
même on ne pouvait pas tu avais beaucoup
d'exigence mais je ne t'en veux pas on
pouvait même pas te filmer pendant
pendant le maquillage qui voulait ça
voilà on va passer un extrait regarde
away
[Musique]
kim son maquilleur depuis cinq ans la
suit aussi par tout
le public ne doit pas voir les étapes de
la transformation de cindy mais juste le
rendu final l'équipe de cindy ne nous
autorise pas à filmer quand elle se fait
maquiller et coiffer
c'est incroyable quand même même pas tu
m'aimes pas qu'on te voit pas malheur
c'est moi qui ne veut pas manfred avait
mis des exigences et vous les bains
j'étais un peu sa petite protégée c'est
vrai que après moi je les bravement
écouter parce que c'est lui qui m'a
tendu la main quand plus personne en
france ne voulait de moi et maintenant
aux télés céline de renard dont mais non
mais tu vois ce que je veux dire c'est
très triste mais maintenant que que
thierry mugler est parti qu'est ce que
tu vas faire mais maintenant j'ai plein
d'idées en tête c'est vrai que quand
j'ai appris son décès je voulais tout
arrêter
et sur le coup bah ça a été des voilà
tout ce qu'on a créé ensemble tout ce
qu'ils voulaient encore faire les
nouveaux projets et je me suis dit non
je ne peux pas je dois terminer cette
boucle en france même si l'étranger move
les bras je veux revenir en france je
reviens en france oui je veux et merde
je plaisante je tu veux revenir en
france j'aimerais chanter j'aimerais
chanter un producteur et un tourneur
d'hui j'aimerais que quelqu'un en france
aujourd'hui me fasse confiance et arrête
d'avoir ce jugement sur cindy sanders et
me convainc pas marc des papillons
lumière quand on a de la chance aussi
après 14 ans oui j'aimerais qu'on passe
un bep mais sait-on que des marins de
sardou maintien bah oui mais aujourd'hui
je la fais en acoustique sur scène et
c'est très beau et voilà mais j'aimerais
aujourd'hui qu'on me donne cette petite
chance de croire en moi et de me donner
une bonne chanson d'accord mais c'est
une question qui est plutôt méchante
mais quand tu dis je la fais en
acoustique sur scène mais tu te produis
sur quelle scène alors je reprends les
scènes là depuis depuis quelques
quelques jours voilà il ya des sanwi il
ya différentes dates de prévues il ya
plein de choses qui sont à leur
championne oui oui et ses dates laurent
c'est vrai qu'avant ben on était
beaucoup à les boulangers maintenant il
ya de nouveau des propositions de la
france accor étudie de quoi aujourd'hui
alors je vis de tout cet argent que j'ai
encore de côté parce que moi je crois
une grande dépense hier non j'aime les
sacs et les amis mais non j'ai c'est
vrai qu'à berlin j'ai très très bien
gagner et après berlin on en fait encore
beaucoup de choses à donges écran